brought to you by far cry primal rise
above extinction in stores februari 23rd
hey guys my name is Jeff it is the 17th
of febri today and you're watching games
button use the ambitious crowdfunded
space sim star citizen has always been
in a bit of hot water for simply not
being out yet today creator chris
Roberts has come out to explain himself
star citizen's original and wildly
successful Kickstarter campaign ended in
2012 and while some parts of the game
are currently playable the full version
is not in an interview with the BBC
Robert says he could have done a better
job of explaining to becca's that the
more money that came in the larger the
scope of the project would grow and
subsequently the later its release date
would become he explained one of the
oxymorons of crowdfunding is you're
asking for money to make this game but
you don't know how much money you're
going to get unless you just want to
pocket the rest of the money which isn't
my thing at all I want to make the best
game possible roberts went on to add
that traditionally games would be
delayed and cancelled behind the scenes
and out of the public eye but with the
project like star citizen that prides
itself on transparency that all happens
publicly he explained the while it can
be difficult to deal with catering to
the literal million armchair developers
who have signed up to track star
citizen's progress the community on the
whole is very supportive and positive
the original kickstarter goal for star
citizen was five hundred thousand US
dollars to date star citizen has raised
over 107 million through crowdfunding
means a whole mess of division things
happen today and here's what you need to
know about that the client for the
upcoming open beta is now available
fizzy to preload oh you won't have any
pesky waiting web service go live the
xbox one version is 23 gigabytes while
the ps4 version comes in at just over
twenty four gigabytes a new open beta
trailer shows off the new mission that
you'll be able to crack into when viewed
from beta lens tomorrow on xbox one and
the day after on PC and ps4 the mission
is called subway morgue where you'll
encounter a faction and as the cleaners
probably more threatening than they
sound finally in 2014 it was stated that
the division of DLC would land on Xbox
one first but now we have a good idea of
just how long ps4 owners will need to
wait a new game stop video suggests that
xbox one players will have a 30 day head
start over the ps4 but the pc version
wasn't mentioned the division will be
getting free pave expansions called
underground survival and last and
finally phone and tablet graphics are
going to catch up to current generation
consoles in 2017 at least that's
according to a leading hardware
manufacturer speaking of the casual
connect conference in amsterdam erm
company director nizar ramdev explained
that the mobile graphics processor
developer has been working with nvidia
samsung and texas instruments on
creating technology capable of rendering
mobile visuals that are on par with home
consoles rundown said if you take
today's high-end smartphone or tablet
the performance is already better than
xbox 360 and playstation 3 it's catching
up quickly with Xbox one and PlayStation
4 he added that the power increase will
likely help out in facilitating cheap of
virtual reality options let me know down
in that comment section what the
best-looking mobile game we've at the
scene has been and be sure to head to
gains that we've got stories and a
neutron game and street fighter 5 online
issues that is everything I have for you
today be sure let me know what you
thought of today's stories and I will
catch you again tomorrow